Karlsson TV is the best kind of TV
rookie mistakes gifting a sub to each
manga something t.t yeah this is my this
is t it's mine cocoa anyway i'm gonna
change the stream title - okay not as
exciting that's plain carlson that's
still oh he's playing he's playing the
penguin a blocks better but it should be
a Chara and black has more space
ooh no it's still oh it's gonna be a
race oh this is so entertaining
so Carlsen over pushed and now penguins
gonna just flag and everything nevermind
oh wow Wow
penguin fightin and a dead wrong
position oh so it doesn't show the
standings here the karlsen's now in
third place
yeah you do not mess with penguin in
like a a time scramble whoa it's Sonia
welcome back some you gifting 5 subs
he's a chess candy cans do believe zig
zag been wh2 and elfric oh shout out to
salsa to Sonia Ling appreciate that yeah
if you're just joining uh I quit the the
playing portion and now I'm watching
Carlson ok Carlson is just crushing this
game like look it's so many ok it's just
yeah it's recyclable for a white
so Alexander is forcing Penguin has been
carlson twice which I'm not surprised
about
okay so I'll hear us is number one
Carlson's number three was big pain what
is opening what's playable okay it's
gonna be sharp this is just a matter of
who can attack quicker Carlson already
has mobster clown storm he just wants to
make it on g2 but this is solid my
ferocious defending well eg for at some
point like destabilizing lights
it's another subtle G tag thanks for
subbing it's hard to break through like
there's no open files like these pawns
we actually just saw the same structure
in the penguin game Carlsen having pawns
like this okay somehow black one upon
yeah the back rink is gonna be weak ooh
okay pawns are falling left rights and
probably Center but this is just good
for black like all the pawns falling for
just tricky though oh but not tricky
enough he just for science yeah he was
down on time Carlsen so strong but he's
braided below 3000 what is this okay
let's open the title arena new tab and
[Music]
okay so the the standings are 75 to 80
so okay still a long ways to go
anything can happen oh thanks for the
comments definitely hollows yeah this
whole stream I I haven't really been
paying much attention to the check
because I've been playing but now I can
maybe look at the chat and try and
commentate
it is hard to do both though
if you have specific opening questions I
see the question from Walid uh maybe
I'll hang around afterwards to answer
but yeah just to give a quick answer the
idea is to to provoke lack to play an
undesirable move to defend the room
anyway what's happening here equal
material very symmetrical pawn structure
never mind with this tree I don't know
who it benefits she blocks probably
doing well because this is a long-term
weakness with bishops of dark squares
you want your pawns on on light squares
when the King is actually quite safe
queenie forest some points now the pawn
was attacked Queen B one O Queen day one
and takes frown into queen g4 that's
probably gonna be another Queen ending
loboc is still better because all these
pawns are at potentially weak i black
swans are more stable
that's my smooth yeah everything's
defended Carlson's so good and like
these things end games but he's slightly
down on time
[Music]
like blacks on the verge of winning but
both players are on the verge of
flagging got 500 it's upon race again oh
that was nice before pushing pawns he
just stopped the white pawn that was
great
that's the type of thing that would have
taken me maybe like ten seconds to
realize so Carlson wins again
he moves to 79 he's only three points
behind firoozeh and he's playing
fruition again this is great
Wow he's playing this b3 shenanigans
[Music]
looks like a reasonable position kind of
some reverse French structure this
bishop is not so happy I'd probably
choose back here like the pawns that's
controlling space another like this is
the second cruiser game we're seeing
with opposite side castling it's just
very sharp this is nice move black can't
take as the rook needs a babysitter and
meanwhile like whites ready to break
through maybe the box also attacking
also whites up the exchange I don't come
when that happens a play is unraveling
so quickly but this looks really solid
for lights like this construction it's a
nice kind of force field like the Queen
can come in but what is it doing here
like whites controlling all of the key
squares and meanwhile there's a pawn
about to promote and the Knights the
Knights been here for almost eternity
wow queen d8 queen d8 is she fine it's a
nice triangle oh it's a four f6 BAM but
weights still probably just winning
for just tricky though he excels in
these like messy positions both sides
are long time
okay Queen probably oh there's gonna be
made on g7 as takes takes takes and then
Queen g7 mate that was nice
my scheme by Carlsen he's so good at
chess so did he that was a critical game
for the overall standings was now he's
in first place and firoozeh has no
streak Carlson's won four in a row the
last loss was actually the first game I
observed lost a penguin now he's playing
green some from Turkey blue grandson in
Carlson was playing like reasonable
openings he's not playing complete
garbage he's not playing any like main
theory I'm just kind of quiet solid
openings what happened to my tournament
I got tilted I tried to recover and then
I quit I think enough people wanted to
watch Carlsen where it made sense to to
retire from playing for a moment what's
going on there's a bishop on b1 trying
to count material whites up upon some
how and why it's also just controlling
all of the center like this is such
great coordination now lights up the
exchange oh that's a fork that's also a
queen trap almost because Queen h6
Bishop g5 and there's so many wins for
light there
oh it's penguin so penguin is also high
up on the leaderboard Carlsen playing
Queens gambit accepted I haven't seen
Carlsen play that in a while yeah so the
last time they played penguin just dirty
facts Carlsen and some Tron ending so
that's preventing away from casting
in wait still can't castle because this
is a threat it's very well controlling
gm1 wow so pawn sacrifice she e4 was a
nice smooth because now the files open
the King can't castle king castles Queen
sign this looks terrible for whites like
whites up a pawn but all it takes is one
check
I hope bishop have to Carlson's so good
with his Bishop moves like attacking
from behind basically it uncovers a rook
and then he'll take and then he's just
up a piece again with these bishop moves
he had 94 fork rook t4 also works 94
would have trapped the Queen I think but
he's up so much material left there's so
many wins Jude danger thanks for subbing
a new sub okay Carlson got revenge on
penguin the streak continues he broke to
you 3000 I think from the previous game
now he's playing Nihal Soren he's
playing really strong players again with
this sort of um it's like a Kings Indian
attack but he starts with E for solid
opening these pawns the structure is
actually quite solid as he has a dark
for a bishop to control the dark squares
I think there is there is a handful
players over 3,000 but it's not an easy
rating to obtain there's one from whole
foods it's called clear mind I think it
like I don't know if it actually makes
my mind clear but it has a placebo
effect any time I drink it it gives me a
clear mind
there just takes and O&I of six is
coming man the rooks can't defend
because upon on d5 and meet is coming oh
this is his force mate I wasn't nice
like he could have taken the rook but
just finds the best continuation that's
nasty
yeah if you want to see how me chest
like the top bullet players I could pull
out the list so let's check the
standings so a few moments ago
Perugia was leading by five points but
now Carlson is leading by five points oh
now he's playing this is Rinaldo Terry
plays a lot on chess table strong player
but not as strong as Carlsen if you like
a lot of games Carlson's team Kettering
this bishop pitch show will you play
something today I already played
something I played a bunch of bookings
and I suffered so now I'm is chilling
this is far less stressful than watching
then playing uh playing bullet it still
takes focus to keep up though also
Carlson's just getting outplayed my
Carlson's down the pawn this rook is
causing havoc over the night okay now I
don't know what's going on what is this
what is this okay this is interesting
but what's going on
od to the king has to take and then
light just loses a knight yeah white
should have taken with a pawn it still
would have been interesting because when
white would win this pawn and white had
what I had enough to maybe be equal but
yeah one one mistake it's just over who
okay another matchup one versus two
Perugia versus Carlson
I wouldn't be surprised and maybe five
years from now this is like the World
Championship match is this what is this
opening I missed it because usually you
don't allowed a night takes III but he
he use that file maybe some secret
opening preparation lobe Red Lobster
welcome back I'm just I'm just sitting
here trying to count the pawns lights up
two pawns black has a bishop hair again
like it seems like every game Carlson's
just in control like this this is such
nice coordination it's a triangle love
of love and defense and now it's a fork
oh but the knight was hanging oh wait
whites position is crumbling or is it
this is hanging what is going on
everything's hanging
I think White's just in big trouble yeah
Carlson's down at Bishop he's gonna try
and promote but like these square is so
unpleasant at the time situation too
he's still fighting
oh there goes a queen Wow Purusha wanna
game and that's that's crucial for the
standings
okay Carlsen I had my one points but
firoozeh on a streak
this is really close okay back to solid
opening is this
I think this is a sorry sorry sorry
[Music]
this is such nice peace harmony the d5
just talking in between move on I have
six coming Wow
I feel like most players I just saw like
although take back not realizing this
like in between three move sequence so
White's up the exchange black has a
little bit of conversation with the
ninth but Carlson is probably just gonna
win at the right moment play Bishop h3
and then the rooks can come in maybe I'm
black being resourceful that's annoying
anytime rock f1 is played by shitty -
haha the bishop is I was nice I've got
trapped and now it's easy
yeah I'm reading the channel it's hard
to like focus on the game and read it
read the chat yeah if they're making you
dizzy just what's the right approach you
have to take like anti-nausea nas nausea
medication or you have to you have to
look out the window I think and then
you'll be less dizzy just drink some tea
now it's really hard to keep up between
the chats and these games because I'll
glance at the chat I'll read like one
comment and then like half the game is
played what to do when faced unusual
move in bullet you just have to react
and rely on intuition the thing about
these players I mean like the intuition
is so strong but Carlson is also able to
calculate really quickly so in the span
of like one or two seconds he can like
if it's a forcing line he can think
several moves ahead which just makes him
incredibly dangerous and bullets so as I
was talking I just wasn't paying
attention to what's going on I'm trying
to count pawns pawns are equal but they
were scattered all over the place black
has a massive attack like queens are off
the board but I wouldn't be surprised if
White's just getting needed cuz rook
here and rook g2 is meat is a main
threat if rook enough to work H ones
mates
that's nasty yeah a big part of bullet
is like intuition and pattern
recognition and Carlson's on just a
whole new level
oh he's playing the exchanged French he
played this assigning of sokovia in the
pro chassis it's actually uh it's a
solid and kind of nice approach to play
a low risk chess I don't know if he has
any advantage here though like these
pawns are kind of ugly yes a bishop
bishop is not
yeah not all the players are public like
if you click their username some names
share their actual names but some don't
this square is very nice for the night
[Music]
that's a nice move I should a bishop do
you want thanks for the five hundred
bits nothing
Nathan Neal I struggle with pronouncing
sometimes but I appreciate that
okay it looks like everything's stable
now material still equal but this is
just such a good ass asset to have in
the end game and there's tension for
black at the right moment well I can
probably take and control one of the
files but maybe no need
like d5 coming get rookie one or that
such good tango yeah it was just torture
for the black Oh what is bits bits are
donations which I I greatly appreciate
so thanks for all the [ __ ] ears okay
Carlos and I believe is still in first
Oh cuz frugal lost again Perugia was
almost catching up but probably lost
with someone else
what do you think of mvl going to
candidates instead of her job off yeah
it's um it's unexpected
I think in some way he's at a
disadvantage because he has so little
time to actually prepare but in another
way I think there's some psychological
damage that he's just grateful to be
there and there's no pressure on him if
he kind of has that that mindset that he
can just kind of create play freely
I mean I wouldn't be surprised if he
wins that'd be insane
imagine he wins candidates and then
defeats Carlsen World Championship you
know you really have to send a thank you
letter to rajala okay so what's going on
Oh Carlsen recent nm blocks up a pawn
block has a bishop here White has this
outside passer have to do with this oh
but this is a passed pawn as well
Wow he just abandons like defending upon
again this Bishop comes alive both
bishops
I mean you hope for somehow slip that
like black plays rock a7 but that would
be illegal because Bach was in check
okay so another win for Carlson creating
a nice cushion above the 3000 rating
yeah I apologize you're not hearing the
computer fan you're hearing the fridge
because a kitchen is your body can move
the mic closer the fridge likes to make
noise us sometimes it'll stop after a
little bit and hello to more people I
appreciate people saying hi when they
join apologies if I didn't say hello to
everyone what to do and facing an
unusual opening like h4 or the forged
offense just follow opening principles
you have to memorize like every single
bit of opening theory just just
understand like basic setups like
control the center get your king safe
try and find harmony among your
especially among your minor pieces how
so many people say hi I appreciate the
greetings again Carlsen's it feels like
a a handful of games Carlson is
following this alpha0 approach of just
putting up on an h3 and that's just a
long-term advantage but okay it's hard
to make use of here it's hard to
teleport the Queen to g2 95 the
counter-attack this is beautiful in
these nights because work after your Chi
2 is just gg yeah check check it's
almost meat or the pawn Falls that was
brutal
oh it's bets from leak wars that's on
your name thanks Lee quartz 700 bets if
I can count
yeah the pawn storms like there's lots
of recurring themes in these games while
Carlsen finally playing an opening that
doesn't involve Fein kattiline I just
want a pawn or did he
yeah there's no e6 because this is
attacked ship c8 what a sad mom it's
usually a bad sign if you have to if you
have to undeveloped in the opening and
you're playing the world champion speech
six again he's probably gonna go for
some attack that's a nice move off the
freezer d4 square for the Queen
he's just winning more stuff or trading
stuff prolly calculating takes or takes
here fresh 93 unexpected I'm not sure if
I understood that materials not equal
and white still solid but Carlson's down
about five seconds this is gonna be
close the thing about bullet though is
that two nights are like almost always
better than nine Bishop cuz they're so
tricky Carlsen trying to catch up on
time doesn't light so powerful and
Knight a5 Navy 94 like the Knights are
so creepy crawly and now likes winning
two pawns place them move moves quicker
than I can draw airless oh that's a fork
yeah nights are so good at forking so
carlson won another game so the last
loss was to firoozeh a long time ago for
just keeping pace though strolling
behind by five points oh it's a penguin
penguins playing the London all this is
fun Carlson Carlson playing kind of the
reverse reverse something all this f6
move f6 is actually becoming a trendy
idea in the structure it's like a
caro-kann exchange yeah I'd really
admired this setup the pawns are kind of
smiling again ladies pawn storms so many
games Carlson's finding a way to get a
black pawn on each three rook g8 maybe
come in Wade that was probably not
intentional but this is now a threat
King h1 that's a calm move so both sides
are gonna be trying to attack on the
keen side this is gonna just be a
slugfest all these squares are
controlled rook e8 maybe Oh but Bishop
c4 was a threat
Akeem does not want to be on he ain't
I like White's position penguin using
his title he spent like five seconds
there but he's still up on time Alec
tina's stole say there's no work a shape
that rooks are disconnected oh there was
this move no there was another it takes
g3 he okay now he's threatening okay Jay
Kingi - so maybe on castling rook g8 so
he just lost a queen but what has
material White has a rook in the night
for Queen again penguin is so good in
these situations
I'm putting my money on penguin even
though Carlson's a long time oh but the
Brooks lost wow it's a job that was a
weird finish I don't know how to digest
that it's like eating a hamburger in
like a second like I I can't digest what
just happened there but okay draw that's
better than losing I guess for either
clear Oh Carlson played this set up
earlier as white now he's playing the
black side of it I like to play the set
up his whites against the modern okay so
it's some kind of exchange looks pretty
equal here I'm actually really curious
to see how Carlson's gonna try and win
this because obviously Clara bishops I
mean it's very very Josh I think if you
do try and win this you'll want to keep
Queens on the board but like what to do
the Queen's always tie down to this pawn
oh but there's weaknesses now Wow
Carlsen making progress kind of but
maybe not really no this is still just a
drama yeah so both players just dancing
but Carlsen pushing for a win he's he's
down like a second c5 that's a move
Carlsen might be over pushing oh this
pawn but he's gonna run up with a king
Wow
if he wins this that's incredible
there's some discovery jack
[Music]
so anytime block gets checked the King
just runs up to to safety
a sevens guarded meanwhile this pawn is
just gonna rot
Wow Carlson is winning this freak Lanka
that's incredible
Carlson gave up f7 I think intentionally
to make it complicated enough and then
just come out on top I don't know how he
did that
cuz the position was so dead huge
respect Oh another another big matchup
okay so ferocious five points behind
he'll he lost his previous game and
they're repeating kind of the same
opening h5 firoozeh was also trying to
get the pawn to h3 Wow so he sacked upon
and he sacked to the exchange all for a
911 call that's tricky if Queen takes d4
there's 92 I think objectively White's
just better but the structure is really
hard to crack like you can never touch
any of these pieces what oh he sucks the
Queen the black threatening meet Carlsen
just resigned because rookie one if I
understand that rookie one Oh takes
takes takes okay so the bishop was gonna
be lost man Wow for vuja one that it's a
risky play it paid off
yeah the type of position is just much
easier to play for black so the the race
for first remains close real quick 122
123 neither firoozeh
nor carlson are on the street
okay I'm just trying to count pawns
White's up upon looks solid this is a
weird night but it's defending them upon
how the night wants to fork like both
sides have holes in their in their king
side so both sides trying to attack each
other
it's a weird game of cat and mouse hey
it's a sub welcome back
Keeney h9x slam for three months yeah
he's too fast for a lot of people but
kudos to the people that can keep up
late box putting up resistance here okay
still down a pawn and down a ton of time
that Carlson is now up three pawns you
don't resigning because Knights are
tricky but yeah four pawns that's enough
oh I could okay I sure ha thanks for
pointing that out
Lee chess counts material for you I've
been trained in my childhood not to look
off the board to look on the board to
count material ok another matchup this
is key it's a standing Carlsen I had my
three points
so if firoozeh wins hee hee leapfrog
Carlsen for first yeah this rating is
crazy mmm
for coming
that doesn't trap the bishop wow so the
bishop took a tour and again like
there's been so many games with like
Carlsen pawn swarming with black on the
Kings side a g4 is nice because now the
g4 is opened and the battery is coming
these bishops doing nothing it's kind of
something but mostly nothing actually
the bishop controls g8 wait what's
actually playing well I should maybe
take that back the bishops were were
quite strong rook is a little bit of a
target
so it takes here other us takes here no
blacks definitely worse and Carlson's
like down over 10 seconds I think
Carlson's gonna lose again
so firoozeh there's no way he survives
this he's playing for tricks
oh you're down three pawns and you're
down below a second
I was rough and four ridges too fast and
too strong so now we see Carlson's in
second version on a streak one point
ahead of Carlson Carlson's Lost's now a
couple games ok this opening looks
incredible for white like Queen h5 is
just lights out the Queen can't come to
g5 is he's Savin would hang this is so
bad for [ __ ] my g4 is resourceful 93
nice move defending defending so black
socked exchange to try and breathe it's
a good decision to keep Queens on the
board because this King is still very
unsafe I'm not sure when the last time
Magnus and Anaka played bullet online
it's been a while
someone needs slow like sponsor a match
and find fine turns they'd be willing to
agree on blocks fighting back kind of
blocks up to pawns but ok the king is
still very unsafe and blocks down the
tunnel tunnel King h9 I forgot to unplug
it but I don't think it registered that
baby will have music later but Carlson's
moves should be music stuff times I
could also turn on pentatonic
I'll turn on pentatonic for one game
don't still meet weights Carlson lost
Carlson got flagged I missed it what
just happened
he was up like ten seconds but black was
tricky Carlson got dirty flags I got
distracted I didn't look at the time oh
that's rough and so now Carlson trailing
firoozeh by five points with under 30
minutes left on the tournament that's
insane
and now his Queens trapped he has to
take on d5 and the tilt now I don't feel
as bad watching Carlson get tilted but
he's okay he's fighting back there's
some potential attack I see six dozen I
smooth smooth maybe oh that's a nice
move a 2 is tender there's this move oh
that's a nice resource but the game
continues
this is still a threat clicking was just
walking up the board that's great
how does white deal with this because
rook d2 just takes G for the King
continues to walk up and now see three o
Queen before forcing the Queen trade the
King is so active okay it's not getting
needed this is gonna be another time
scramble I'll pay attention this time
like these pawns are menacing yeah you
can't meet progress is flat whoa
Karlsson lost again Carlsen lost I can't
even count that high
three games in a row or four games three
games in a row
ouch wait refresh oh there's me ouch
and now he keeps playing strong players
in perugia Oh freesia also lost a game
so it's still close it's still a
five-point difference between the two
GM Kantian shoutout to Jean Canty thanks
for tuning in not sure if you're
reciting poetry or lyrics or just making
up senses but I guess everyone will have
their own interpretation these are okay
again like Carlsen pawns swarming so
many games this plan storm actually
looks really nice whenever black takes
threes at five meanwhile yeah White's
just gonna pile up on f5 bh5 here
ah so blacks also piling up hmm Karlsson
up almost 10 seconds once after takes
the Box gonna get that five square
expecting takes all the bishops pinned
whoa Bishop efore weather move look f3
oh what a response
what's material me chess isn't telling
me I'm trying to count Black has a bunch
of pawns and a bunch of pieces around
the King G v g5 it's gonna be mates
almost King g4 oh he socked the Queen
okay now it's a race again I don't know
how that how to digest these moves it's
just a time scramble now Carlsen up
three seconds you just have to give spy
checks
wow he mates he mates that wasn't nasty
I was so nasty oh okay man need to find
some popcorn like a lot of these games I
just don't know how to digest the moves
unfold so quickly there's so many plot
twists
okay this we have some kind of Berlin it
seems a relatively equal not sure how
that's relevant but again I guess thanks
for the bits
Carlson was trying to build up slow
slowly but surely a five may be coming
like I think in in a slower game it
should just be a draw but in bullets
it's gonna come down to sometime
scramble Carlson trying to milk some
advantage he's making progress like the
night coming to e6 or c6 there's some
holes in Locke's position this is
incredible like the King just walked up
and he's fiend cow doing the king in
blacks territory firoozeh resigns
because it looks long right I think it
looks long I guess there's a night here
but the night's gonna come around and
win the pawn wow what a what the king
walk that was inspiring
[Music]
that's incredible I thought it was just
a draw
I guess Carlson doesn't believe in
fortresses wait what what no I missed it
I was I was trying to interpret a
comment in the chat and Carlson just
dropped his queen did that really just
happen you just lost a game yeah he just
lost yeah hehe was not expecting Knight
takes c6 yeah that's a sign of tilt
maybe some fatigue yeah if you turned
away you missed it I almost missed a -
someone needs to clip it if it's not too
late
okay this position looks quite nice I
think for the most part
Carlson's been beating Soren
okay so you won the exchange now this
should be a smooth wind yeah if you ever
play Carlson that's the way to go you
just go for some trick Oh pinkie pre
moves but that previous game I don't
think it was a trick it was just uh a
slight sideline that rook d7 coming ouch
so for rusian I assume lost the streak
but he's still in first by one point
this is gonna be really close
[Music]
Kings Indiana it's an opening that
that's easy to play in bullets again
Carlson with alpha0 pawn that's regard
how's it going good to see you shout out
to the the future Grand Master I turn
away in like half the pieces come off
the board it's still a very close
position not easy to break through but
all white needs is a queen on g7 just
how to get there here here here
Wow a knight f6 so he has two plants but
this structure looks still safe for
black g5 cementing now maybe blocks okay
and these pawns are just smiling
yeah White has to make sure that can't
play coin off for rookie five nice move
maybe White's going for this idea while
Rick takes d5 because mating ideas upon
was pinned to e7
but Carlson forgot about the Queen pin
and now he's just losing but he's
threatening Queen b8 wow this is gonna
be a wait what is this position White's
just winning White's winning cuz of the
rook in the King Nate they're stuck
that's incredible
[Music]
look at that crossing somehow traded
Queens he's seven Black has no no escape
all these things are stuck he just walks
a king and he could also just walk the
king who promote the Queen side pawns it
was incredible because he lost her for
seemingly nothing he still want a six I
mean that's the type of game that that
can be until ting give it all the
tragedies Carlson has had okay now he's
doing things to White's things there's
so many games were Carlson just somehow
winds up on oh but now he's losing a
pawn now he's losing another pawn king
of six nine of three blocks down the
pawn here but Knights are tricky but
both sides have Knights so I don't know
what to make of this and both sides
attacking rooks black is still down the
pawn you look oh there's 92 maybe a
black loss to another pawn so it's gonna
be a race White has three three on zero
verse 2 on zero so I don't know how
relevant extra pawn is it's more about
how close the pawns are to queening
but with mites on the board it's still
very tricky oh this is meat
I was just about to say there's some
meeting ideas Wow he just made it it
looked like it was gonna be a pawn race
[Music]
but yeah me neither is a very important
tactic in all stages of the game
so Carlson's back in first but firoozeh
also on some streak it's still a 1-point
difference yeah no one's running away
with it
where's where's the penguin penguin is
kind of far behind but a solid third
some weird opening a six coming a five
maybe a queen bee foam green sea fine
[Music]
feels good when I can predict a couple
most what's the prize fund maybe someone
can answer that it should be posted
[Music]
check real quick oh it's um it's right
here 504 first I think it's a thousand
dollars total prize fund blocks just up
to pawns these pieces this piece is so
out of it
how does black have a pawn on e5 the
pawns here here and here somehow
probably there is some capture or there
is there's probably this like double
capture blocks so up to pawns
has to defend Queen f6 wait this is not
easy because the time situation
how Queen asked for what a move because
made back remaining ideas Carlson's so
far down on time but he's going insane
with this pre moves but can he win this
with two seconds he made the king of the
center the kiemce just got hugged by
blacks pieces
it was incredible finished the nasty pre
moving some really nasty pre moving
look at that me too well what do we call
this I don't know it's like a sandwich
from all directions it's like a sandwich
where there's bread on on four sides not
just two sides okay so now we have a
scandi and 94
how about castles Queen side f7 is kind
of weak now that's a nice move cuz
White's keeping initiative and wins by
seven but didn't take f7 probably
because the bishop was hanging so it's
equal material this reminds me of the
firoozeh game from earlier where it
looked like it was just gonna be a draw
but okay here white one upon but even if
white didn't win the pawn like this is
my space advantage can like build more
space I think here the plan is very
simple just make a password like the
knight is kind of out of it ouch
yeah Carlson's back in for him like he
went through a rough patch for like
three games but firoozeh still keeping
pace is still when a point tournament h
okay he's going insane oh he's playing
he's playing the hammer he's playing his
his compatriots I don't know if I've
seen have her play on me chest yes he he
knows how to treat the hammer the move
move to h4 ok pawns are falling or the
South Fork there's not a six but again
this pawn after like do some analysis
and see how many names he gets a pawn on
each six was white or as on h3 is black
it was very alpha zero like it's just
like long term worries for the
opponent's Knights pinned now this
lights tied down to the fighting this
night but moves anyway his discovery but
now this light has kind of pinned had to
move back
how hurt a c7 light was pinned if takes
her takes her stakes and if takes her
was mate nice finish that's great you
just take a thing that's defended by
three things but not really defended by
three things
[Music]
who he's playing Jigoku it's one of the
top players on the chess okay we have a
monitor this is not the first time
firoozeh has entered this tournament
versions I think one the last few titled
arena's I'm not sure when Carlson won
the last type of arena also what just
happened
this doesn't look good for that black
just black only has three pawns left
White's off four pawns here now three
pawns but still like all of lacks pawns
just kind of vanished also Torrey in the
chat shadows Goldust Torrey I think I
have a G DD command yeah GD team yeah if
you're just joining Carlson's playing in
the lead chest Harlan arena it's a very
close race between Carlson and Perugia
also what's about to Queen every time I
look away like the position changes
dramatically blocks trying to mate on e
to light castles this was never too late
to castle accept the Queen's hanging now
but this Queen's hanging so rook takes
g3 takes with check what a move Knight G
through so it's a queen trade this is
still hanging that the queen is gonna
come back to wife so after all said and
done blacks was down in exchange but now
is only down upon but White's about to
flag I was so fixated on a position I
didn't see what's time white with some
strong pre moving it's not gonna help ya
it all it takes is a few spy checks
Oh Federica you can't spell feather
recall without Derrick I think anyway um
what's uh the overall Oh fer Russia lost
and Carlson Carlson Carlson has won the
last thing I can't count six games seven
games
he's on a nasty streak also what is his
position he's hacking a queen
because if takes takes takes and then
it's a fork in the end but there's Queen
a5 in the end so he doesn't take the the
rook cuz 25 so he has a wait he's down
the Queen for a rut but he has pawns
again I'm trying to count its rook into
pawns for a queen yeah Carlson got a
little bit too feisty in the opening and
now the pawns about to push I mean oh
that's a good move I was about to say
that
it's gonna be resigning before White's
but I'm still trying to fight yeah this
is not easy to win for black does this
thing as a fortress like even if Carlsen
doesn't believe in fortresses and
honestly Carlsen might be playing for a
win with a time situation over G for
coming mmm d4 ah the pawns are falling
like just resigns
wow so Carlson's streak ends Perugia won
a game and another game Wow so it's
still at one point difference and
they're playing each other versions on
the street if firoozeh wins he leapfrogs
Carlsen
this game I mean there's eight minutes
left but this game could very possibly
decide the tournament and now we see
Carlson actually playing like actual
opening theory and some some sort of
mainline Spanish looks like I assume c6
I mean I've studied like Carlson's black
games against the Spanish and he's
played this sort of structure many times
Wow what does this move oh it's a
discovery so white one upon Karlsson
down the pawn but has some some decent
pieces ok White's just better here up
upon super solid though it is easy to
play for a black like rook e8 f6 at the
right time you want to take and
penetrate I thought I definitely found
some compensation and whites kind of tie
it up Wow Bishop takes e4 and I take C
for the sacrifice but does it work he
sat to peace but now he has more pawns
as pawns weak this pawns weak and he's
up about 10 seconds and c3 may be coming
all the pawns are falling ferocious last
hope is this pawn but it doesn't look
too hopeful like rook a to or even King
d6 first row k-6 is nice
oh it's gonna be meat but okay you saw
it wait this is gonna be a time scramble
uh-oh Carlson now down on time freeze
was gonna win Wow bruiser whine Carlson
was up about 10 seconds and had like
amazing play with pawns but
Persia held on Wow he's so fast and so
strong okay so there is less than six
minutes left
and now faroush is on a streak and it
has a three point lead so the whole
Carlson desert Carlson deserts against
an almost 2,900 Cuzzi he's really just
has to catch up it's a sign of tilt this
is not gonna end well for a white king
f3 maybe wow the Keen going for a walk
now black has time to calculate Queen h3
Keaney for Brooke g4 the King's gonna
get brutalized in the center oh dear Oh
f4 nice move you just have to shelter
your king from all directions but the
Kings lacking shelter
look at this King it's on e4 Queen e6 is
almost a main threat the King just went
like this okay the Knights gonna fall
and this is meets ouch
that's rough the king went like this
listen got needed again the berserk from
Carlsen firoozeh firoozeh won another
game so now there's a seven-point me
Carlson collapsing I mean he needs to
string together some wins some desert
winds and he just lost her go yeah he's
just falling apart even though he he won
Connect four for a moment there I was
just a complete collapse
now it looks so promising to just one
really bad game he resigns again yeah
you can't bezerk against so fun who's
over 3,000 oh okay this is is there
still hope I mean he's not gonna be Zerg
firoozeh but we have time on earth maybe
some sort of time on of cod I play those
openings black so this is fun to see
and I'm rooting for Carlson to make it
close firoozeh has has an 11-point lead
there's no way Magnus is catching up
even if he wins this game
[Music]
like this position it's equal material
but I'm gonna say this pawn is slightly
weird but now it looks balanced time is
reasonable for both sides as opposed to
prawns it happens it's always some
misunderstanding with language and
seafood rook takes you six yeah I
Carlson's I think is gonna lose another
game or at least it's gonna be a draw
that's all that's needed whoa it's a kg
707 oh that's just made into out
yeah firoozeh just clinched it with that
things for the gifted Suggs so is that
does that spell Carlson's final game
there's less than two and a half minutes
yeah nitrous teen has paused ting
probably can't catch up firoozeh we'll
watch him and a new tab yeah it looks
like looks like Magnus is done
it's kind of sad things a Canty 707
gifting subs to Torquay TV pure gold
I'm Joel skill Jim space there's a queue
qym space and meeting threatens yeah
this could very well be the last game
for version also yeah those five gifted
subs there is not a high probability of
getting a sub gift with over 1100 people
watching thanks people for watching hope
you're entertained and inspired also
yeah Congrats to Persia whoo
without a doubt winning this tournament
also alpha0 pong but these pawns are I
think are stronger than any sort of
alpha zero pawn white just wants to
teleport the Queen but D - coming Queen
d2 will be very sad well I wanted to
play this button can't these pieces the
pieces are frowning and you just a push
to a pawn ooh it's a meat threat yeah
good job to forego for not taking the
rock again White's ready-made in two
different ways but at the same time
likes losing everything so nice finish
this nice seam to finish things I assume
pairings are closed I could join let's
join the hot pair internal caring's are
now closed okay I think I made the I
think a good decision to withdraw from
the tournament and and just watch that
epic finish I really look like Carlson
was gonna was gonna finish strong with
like this amazing streak and firoozeh
was stumbling a little bit but then
Frisia just went on a rampage Carlson
collapsed trying to berserk the last
several games yeah some nice confetti
also congrats to penguin who we saw
earlier it was also fighting but he
defeated Carlsen a few times I think if
we click a name here yeah we can see all
like the stats I'll leave a link I'll
leave a link in the chat if people want
to to check out the the final standings
but firoozeh had a 78 percent win rates
thank you Alexander's horse appreciate
that yeah I appreciate like all the
viewership is a fun a fun tournament to
watch it's a little bit difficult to
play I'll probably put this on youtube I
don't know if following through the part
of me playing on YouTube or just include
the watching Carlson information parts
Tang had a 37 percent buzzer crates Wow
63% yeah that's what happens when you
berserk
but tinkin berserk and beat like a lot
of strong players yeah so congrats to
bruza good try to Carlson good job
penguin big things to leech s4 running
this event sponsoring a nice prize fund
in fifth place fifth place 150 bucks
fourth place 175 dollars I just want a
hundred bits from are we supposed to
trying to say things but not saying
things entirely harp eyes a noodle
things for the 2,000 bits yes so all
I'll put this on YouTube thanks people
in the future watching on YouTube and
the presidents watching live on Twitch
and thanks yeah thanks to everyone also
things to leech us someone was asking is
this where my leech has donations are
going leech s is very public with their
finances
if you dig on their website you can find
a spreadsheet to see where a donation
money is going I think you can h9x plan
I wish I could say the same about your
poetry but some of your poetry is kind
of insightful I guess
uh we have the Sheep laughter thanks
again but yeah me chess is entirely like
donation-based so I think most of
donations run or go towards running the
servers and they also so they also have
a youtube channel which I know they're
they're putting out more content on
people can find probably very easily
anyway thanks again people I'll leave
links in the description and yeah if you
just joined you can watch in the future
on YouTube